el 31 de agosto si será la fecha final
de las evacuaciones en kabul eeuu
reiteró su postura en la reunión virtual
del g7 del martes afirmando que sus
tropas están en un peligro creciente
estamos encaminados a finalizar el
proceso para el 31 de agosto cuanto
antes mejor cada día de operaciones
aumenta el riesgo para nuestras tropas
pero esto depende de que el talibán siga
cooperando permitiendo acceso al
aeropuerto de las personas que estamos
sacando del país y que no haya
interrupciones a nuestras operaciones
racing y eeuu no es el único planeando
su retirada francia anunció que es muy
probable que termine con las
evacuaciones este mismo jueves
es muy probable porque desgraciadamente
los estadounidenses confirmaron la fecha
del 30 de nuevos son quienes controlan
el aeropuerto y por las condiciones
prácticas y de seguridad no podremos
continuar las operaciones más allá del
31 de agosto nos estamos preparando para
que las últimas evacuaciones puedan
ocurrir antes del fin de semana hacia
parís vía abu dhabi bus que pague desde
un inicio reino unido- buscó extender la
fecha límite y ahora afirma que
trabajarán hasta el último minuto para
evacuar tantas personas como puedan
está claro que las tropas se retirarán a
fin de mes y lo que haremos es usar cada
hora y día que queda para sacar a
nuestros nacionales como podamos y a los
afganos que trabajan para nosotros a
otros los más recientes anuncios solo
han aumentado la presión en kabul miles
acuden al aeropuerto internacional
intentando huir mientras el talibán
prohibió a los afganos acudir al
aeropuerto señalando a las tropas
estadounidenses de dispararles a los
civiles algo que los militares
extranjeros refuta